now those of us who write books are
seldom happy with what the movie makers
do to our creations I am still the news
by the fate of my lovely heroine Myra
Breckinridge who became overnight first
a movie and then 600,000 celluloid
guitar picks but unlike most authors I
cannot complain as a contract writer at
MGM class of 54 I was personally
responsible for sabotaging several
distinguished novels and so I have only
the highest respect for those adapters
who managed beautifully to illustrate
the screen with works that first came to
life on the page and the nominees for
the best screenplay adapted from other
material are Barry Lyndon screenplay by
Stanley Kubrick
the man who would be king screenplay by
John Huston and Gladys Hill One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest screenplay by
Lawrence Halpern and Bo Goldman scent of
a woman screenplay by Rajaram Akari and
Dina Risi
the sunshine boys screenplay by Neil
Simon and I'll tell you the winner if
they bring me down
the winners are Laurens husband and Bo
golden for One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest
Hevy there and now I'm supposed to steps
aside to the left well thank you for
this to the members of the Academy and I
especially want to thank the producers
Saul Zaentz and Michael Douglas who gave
me the opportunity to come to contact
and work with some of the most the
finest people I've ever known thank you
I loved writing this movie and it seems
redundant to me to receive an award when
the only award I ever wanted was a
chance to write a script like this may I
shared this honor with my wife mAb
Ashforth and my friend and agent Arnold
Stifel thank you members of the Academy